well giving back during these very  difficult times ccsd police along with  the learner in roe foundation handed out  some turkeys to those who may need some  extra help right now  this was earlier today over at ruby  thomas elementary school  organizers tell us it's important to  reach out and give back  it makes us feel good to get back to the  community we would just ask you know  everybody you know check on your  neighbors make sure that they're doing  all right  you know and you know you can't really  gather together but you know see if they  need anything and you know  always look for these community events  we post things like this on facebook  all the time whenever stuff pops up  and organizers tell us they delivered  more than 700  turkeys to local families